[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous propose de découvrir
Sciences Po Saint-Germain en lait c'est
un IEP donc un Institut d'études
politiques on y apprend les sciences
social créé en 2013 à l'initiative des
universités de Versailles Saint-Quentin
en Eveline et de g Pontoise mais la
particularité de cette école c'est son
ouverture sur le monde avec plus de 80
partenaires à l'étranger et des échanges
académiques c'est une école qui propose
de nombreuses opportunités pour partir à
l'international allez c'est
[Musique]
parti pour commencer on va assister un
cours sur les violences faites aux
femmes ce cours il est délivré en
anglais par Débora Galimberti qui est
professeur et également responsable des
affaires
[Musique]
internationalesent l'idée délivrer des
cours en anglais c'est pour renforcer la
maîtrise de la langue pour les étudiants
pour des questions d'insertion
professionnelle mais c'est aussi une
question en fait d'ouverture d'ouverture
vers des controverses académiques pour
encourager les étudiants à lire des
articles des études publié en anglais
donc c'est une forme d'ouverture en fait
vers vers les monde vous enseignez mais
vous êtes également directrice de tout
ce qui concerne l'international ici quel
est l'importance en fait de cette
dimension internationale à Science Po
Saint-Germain ENL ce n'est pas
uniquement à label donc une question
d'affichage mais c'est plutôt une
pratique hein donc une pratique
justement euh qu'on retrouve dans dans
les cours hein mais qu'on retrouve aussi
dans des conventions des partenariats
pour la mobilité internationale
euh vous avez plus de 80 partenaires oui
on a plus de 80 partenaires dans tout
dans dans les monde et donc tous les
étudiants de Sciences Po à la 3e année
passent une année à l'étranger et on
accueille chaque semestre une
cinquantaine d'étudiants
[Musique]
bon je ne sais pas pour vous mais moi ça
m'a donné envie de voyager je vais r ici
mais je vous propose d'écouter le
témoignage d'Alice peré une étudiante
actuellement en échange en
Malaisie partie en Malaisie en 3e année
de Sciences Po parce que c'est une année
d'échange universitaire mais ce que
j'aime bien c'est l'enthousiasme des
personnes que elle parle de leur trad
elles veulent en apprendre plus voilà
disent ah j'aimerais bien aller à Paris
où je suis déjà allée en Europe et
ensuite on échange
c'était une volonté de ma part de partir
dans une culture très éloignée de
l'Europe pour avoir justement ce ce
dépaysement total et ce renversement
même de point de vue sur le
[Musique]
monde
et sur le campus il y a aussi des
étudiants étrangers l'association World
facilite leur intégration on va aller
les
rencontrer salut Nathan bonjour ça va
oui et vous oui ben ça va merci bah
alors on est dans les locaux de
l'association World c'est ça exctement
c'est ça donc là on est la
science on est l'association World et
derrière mes membres sont en train de
faire une réunion pour organiser les
événements ok ben je peux me joindre à
vous pas de souci super B allez on y
va bonjour Bour ici qui est-ce qui a pu
bénéficier des services de l'association
world
progamucechucance
[Musique]
c'est difficile pour un étudiant
étranger par exemple devenenir dans un
campus où il connaî personne bien sûr il
y en a qui parlent pas du tout français
donc on doit les aider avec tout tout ce
qui est procédure administrative des
trucs tout simples comme faire leur
Navigo et C on les accompagne on les
aide quand ils comprennent pas leur
employer du temps et cetera notre
mission c'est c'est de les aider aussi
qu'il puissent profiter de leur année
ici donc qui participent aux événements
les événements sportifs culturels et
cetera et quand vous dites promouoir
qu'est-ce que vous organisé par exemple
ce lundi on a organisé un événement donc
en collaboration avec une une une
professeure d'origine indienne qui nous
a initié au baratantiam donc une une
danse traditionnelle indienne et c'est
le pôle asile donc le pôle Apica qui
s'est qui s'est chargé d'organiser cet
événement et on était une quinzaine
d'étudiants à découvrir cette cette
nouvelle danse venue d'ind mais
j'imagine que c'était sympa oui c'était
super sympa on tout le monde a bien
rigolé c'était une manière de découvrir
une nouvelle culture qu'on ne connaît
pas du tout qu'on connaît peu tout ça
dans le respect et et tout en étant
inclusif et
[Musique]
cetera et voilà c'est ainsi que se
termine notre vie visite à sciencep
Saint-Germain en laai une école qui vous
l'aurez compris est tourné vers
l'international avec des programmes
dessinés pour la mobilité à l'étranger
des professeurs et des étudiants engagés
c'était sciencep Saint-Germain
[Musique]
en
mi Federica d'Antonio stud
internaleengo Torino
[Musique]
Italia